squad being mocked for taking victimhood
to a whole new level at least 17 members
of congress were arrested at a supreme
court abortion protest for blocking
traffic and guests who made a big fool
of themselves
alexandria ocasio-cortez and ilhan omar
pretending to be handcuffed while being
led away by police both walking with
their hands behind their backs but it
turns out they were just pretending with
aoc throwing her fist right up in the
air
the congresswoman complaining later over
people calling her out labeling them as
right wing lunatics
republicans favorite hobby is to make
conspiracy theories out of everything to
distract you and keep you from talking
about what's actually important which is
the fact that they are trying to take
away your right to bodily autonomy if i
was faking that why would i
intentionally fist pump somebody it's so
silly yeah aoc adding on twitter quote
no faking here putting your hands behind
your back get this is a best practice
while detained handcuffed or not to
avoid escalating charges like resisting
arrest now of course liberal media
falling for the charade outlets like abc
posting these photos with their hands
behind their backs
now okay let's talk about this dana you
seem to be getting the biggest charge i
mean this is my favorite story it is all
right well then what what what why did
she put her hands behind her back she is
really not worried about the best
practices when you're arrested she even
knows i really think she should put that
out as a public service announcement
because i didn't know that i didn't know
that's what you should do when you are
about to get arrested yeah do you
remember the tick tock democrat the tick
tock texans when they fled texas and
they went to washington dc and they were
hiding out and basically just doing
videos and they were saying how terrible
things were but they were eating at
fancy restaurants this takes this
political stunt to a whole new level so
move over now you've got aoc and the
apple dumpling gang
when i was a kid at the end of school i
would love to play school
she wanted to go to congress of course
so that she can play
congress but here's the thing at
congress you can pass laws what were
they doing as jessica has pointed out
what were they doing from the days that
the leaked draft of the possible
decision
of roe v wade to when it was announced
what were they doing in all those times
but you know the first thing she did
yesterday after she made an instagram
video she sent out a fundraising email
because that's what this is all about
that's how they're they're making money
on your
being upset about roe v wade if you're
upset about that what she's doing they
are pretending to protest and they are
taking your money and they're doing
nothing with it well you know jesse i
saw you do that you know that hive fist
the truth is that the liberal media did
fall for it what they did do was they
showed them going with their hands
behind their backs with a police officer
next to them so the liberal media kind
of engaged in that and for people who
are low information voters they say oh
wow she really believes in that look at
ilhan right there she's got her hands
behind her back aoc looks like she has
her hands behind her back they're not
joking around are they no and and that's
what they wanted they wanted that shot
of them like this on abc so they could
look like heroes
she says she's doing this to de-escalate
the situation
okay
from what she's not rodney king she's
not getting batons smacked across her
skull they gave her free bottled water
and bananas afterwards these are the
nicest cops ever and this is after a
week before she was saying these capitol
hill police officers were not protecting
her from sexual harassers and were in
on january 6th and now she's like
throwing herselves at these officers
like they're her co-stars oh cuff me
please she's such a great actress she
actually said this week she's not
getting paid enough to be a
congresswoman go to hollywood aoc
because you can't legislate she's the
least productive member of congress but
boy they say lights camera action and
she is right out there she got a 50
ticket so i guess it's worth it i mean
she can't make ends meet but something
frivolous will be well obviously her
fiance is not making enough money for
all right jessica what do you have to
say about
this it's always frustrating for me when
a good cause and something that is
important and protesting this decision
is something that's important our new
fox polling shows that 70 of americans
are upset about the decision that
doesn't mean 70 of americans are for
abortion with no limits we know that the
vast majority want a 15-week ban put in
place um but they do want people to be
able to get reproductive health care so
when you do this and then the story
switches over to that and i'm it's not
only conservatives that are going to be
talking about it it's going to be
moderate democrats that are talking
about it or someone like carolyn maloney
actually who was out there as well but
you didn't see footage of her she was
just out there talking about the cause
that has mattered to her for through
decades of public service talking about
her record what she was doing and
supporting the people who are rightfully
upset about this and
maybe it's a feature of having worked
with
some fantastic conservative colleagues
but i always look at stories for what is
going to happen to the other side when
they get their hands on this and you
know for a fact if you're voluntarily
putting your hands behind your back
that people are going to seize on that
and they're not going to talk about the
fact that in 26 states now it's
basically illegal to get an abortion so
that's what i think about it
basically illegal
well is that not true no it's not okay
we're not going to do the abortion
argument
okay but he did we've been through it
do you think let's keep it light do you
think maybe she had invisible handcuffs
on yes i've i've seen them i actually
ordered a few on amazon
but
we you got to understand for many people
being arrested is a new virtue signal
for gaining status there are at least
two people i know at this building or
we're in this building who like to brag
that they've been arrested somebody that
we know oh i was arrested in blah blah
blah i was arrested it's like oh you
were arrested and you think and you th
you know who one of them is oh i did and
and the thing is
but their arrest is like no more severe
than having somebody coming to read your
gas meter they pull you over they write
a ticket and you're what was 50 bucks is
what she paid it isn't about her though
really it is about the media like you
said and their willingness to cooperate
in stories that they love they never
would have played along with a pro-lifer
or a republican or a gun rights person
if they did this little fake thing they
would call them out that's why we have
to do it because the mainstream media
won't and i and um what was i going to
say this is more evidence that what the
media does is it it it doesn't
it doesn't present real things but
representatives of things it's like that
little trash can on your laptop that's
not really a trash can right when you're
dragging things into it it's just an
icon and that's what the media loves to
do is create icons this is kind of a
funner
lighter version of whip gate right the
picture that was that was sent around
over and over and all you saw was a you
know a black migrant an evil border
patrol agent a whip all of that
these are all like little icons and then
when you tap on them and you find out
that's not really what it is and every
and so we have to do that because
basically no one no one else will
so there you go all politics is theater
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now